I know there's a lot of paradigms on how
to understand the internal aspects I
have my own okay it's a combination of
experience and
then academic study that that makes a
unique
perspective in other words if you if you
only study one end of the Silk Road or
even less what your teacher said like
your teach teacher's lineage the text
related to your teacher's lineage it's
very
small so it adds a very unique
perspective
and a problem that is very common and
that you might have is that you adopt
a a mechanical understanding of
things very machine like
the machine like world view is ego
tripartite worldview and you should at
the second you
spot this machine model you should just
immediately go it's wrong that's not
right and you should strive constantly
to subvert the Machine model where it
doesn't make
sense so in the Machine model of the
internal aspects this is why a lot of
people try to talk about it's connective
tissue or it's
fascia right or then you have other
people go no there's Chi but Chi is just
electricity or
electromagnetic forces they're looking
for a machine
model you know they they they they they
give Chi you have other subtler
paradigms but it's still a machine model
so you know oh cheese she's real and
like it has material space you know it's
not electricity it's not magnetism it's
not fascia but they you still pay
attention how they're using it and it
still has a materiality to it that is
part of a machine model and this is not
this is not accurate okay if you if you
study out the whole technology of self
it's not
accurate so when one of the things that
I say that I usually goes past you is
that you you cannot no one ever can no
one ever has separated mind from
Che and I don't
try they interchange it I don't care
however mind is not what we might think
of mind like a lot of people think mind
is intention but that's a machine model
that's not what I mean or some people
would think mind is what Freud said or
what Yung said no that's not what I mean
or some people will think it's uh what
Ian mcgilchrist is saying he's got the
two hemispheres of the brain was like
that's a machine model it's a machine
model that's not it either you you have
to figure out what do you mean by mind
well I mean ego tripartite mind or I
mean God mind and sometimes I use the
synonym
experience experience
being mind she same
thing and you pick the upic term you
need to use to get the practitioner
there where's there aware away from the
Machine model
okay so we're we're going to again take
another step at this with that preface
don't get trapped in the Machine model
okay and we're not going to separate CH
and mind
we know we're going to form a
tanden but the tonden as I understand
it's not in a location in your
body and you don't make a location in
your body so you have people like in
iido and they just say you use your
tonden it's a everyone has it you might
have other people like dammo who will
say no you learned how to form it but
it's actually in your body and I say no
okay the tanden is a manifestation of a
process it's only as long it's only
there as long as the process is being
utilized okay and the process is that
you're going to internalize young aspect
notice I didn't say Yang electricity
yangong force or even Yang chat just
Yang aspect at this
point the Yang aspect is going to be
ground vectored off the ground this
transforms it I don't know why it just
[Music]
does it starts a Yin aspect to that
young aspect it converts it it comes
back up and it meets the continuing
internalizing Yang aspect and it meets
it in the midsection of the body and
when those two meet that's the
[Music]
tonden where this is in your body where
the two
meet it
is either gross or subtle depending on
your skill
which
means your ability to perceive it to
experience it your
mind awareness of
it so right now your awareness is really
low you don't know what to feel for
that's what it is and you could say as
if you had a machine model you would say
oh I'm thickening the
chi that's a machine model and there's a
materiality to the chi there and I say
no that's not it it's more that your
mind is more a uh aware more capable of
sensing it and it feels and acts as if
it is thicker than for someone else who
is just I I can't feel it at all to
someone a little more aware a little
more skilled that goes oh I have a wisp
of it I felt it it's like a wisp of it
and when you are more advanced it's it's
like a feels thicker I I can barely
touch it where another person might not
feel it at all but I feel like I'm
touching a brick wall and I could move
from there but there's obviously no
brick wall and there's no true thick or
thinness there's just the experience of
thick or thinness
okay at the beginning I think sometimes
we get
confused because this yinong aspect is
constantly
functioning it's just we're not aware of
it and it Alters according to actual
physical forces this is why for
example um you use your hands your hands
is mudra right well they're taking shape
and space But as they're taking shape
and space they're generating physical
forces centripetal forces centrifugal
forces right and they're changing the
center of gravity of my my body and this
moves those yin and yang
aspects and at the beginning you don't
feel that you just a lot of people don't
even feel the centrifugal or the
centripetal forces in iido even though
you're doing circles they just don't
feel it they don't feel the blood go to
their fingertips you know and then as
you get more trained oh yeah I could
feel it I could feel there is a force
pulling the UK out and that's the force
I'm going to use when I throw them right
right they can feel that Force the
beginner they can't feel it they just
picture the throw from what they're
doing but those forces will move this
Yin and yangong
aspects okay and we're moving them when
we move our hands when we move our arms
when we lower our Center we're moving
them and the more you are aware of it
and the thick it feels again a
poetic it's not that I
am so much moving my arms as much as
that thing's moving my
arms okay but we're going to reverse it
at the beginning because it is
interrelated okay so we're doing tyo
henko and what we're trying to do here
is
get those centrifical centrifugal
centripetal forces going okay that's
what we're trying to do trying to feel
those forces okay those are more gross
than the chi the chi is more subtle you
want to be able to feel those okay so
when you're doing tyo heno there's
several things that you're trying to
you're not just
going or
I'm not just
exercising I'm trying to feel these
forces so couple
things if you can already
feel the gravitational pull of your
mass that's a
force feel
it because that's what you end up using
all
along so you can start
there I feel that and I feel his energy
and I add that energy down okay I feel
that I can feel for the spiral movement
of the
mudra don't confuse I'm just going slow
so you I can talk and you can see it
bring your breath into
it receive
inhale settle
exhale settle feel it
drop open Loud on on the
hands look how they'll aim at each other
start to feel for his
body the eyes the eyes don't look
around the eyes that see
is the ego triarte
mine don't
look you you want to have Zen
eyes does it matter on the version I go
forward and
in or I turn
in doesn't
matter Marshall
this part this entry is
key make sure it's happening in the
right place it happens here back behind
this
corner
here four
elbows heavy P your elbow
weight on your mid foot VOR hold your
hands on your midfoot vector shoulder on
your midfoot
vector this
pivot is is the other the only other
martial aspect in here the
timing and the single pivot so don't
slack on
that you see that
[Music]
when you're
UK
stock
low hunting killing
mine killing
mine low feel there t
in
but surrender The Killing mind is a
surrendering mind surrender under death
so as I'm walk as I'm walking into here
I don't give a crap what happens to my
body that's the stalking
mind so said he hits me in the body I
don't care
do it
hard it doesn't
matter so you're
already loaded with that Co you're
already loaded with it it's just I now
aren't the active agent in the technique
do you do you understand I Surrender
unto injury death
in let him
decide when the technique's
done then back out protect yourself
stock
in okay train like that not with that
other goopy stuff and get this
centrifugal
cpal forces pulling on those yin and
yang aspects okay
try Okay so remember I said at the
beginning of this I'm already using
my my material aspect my material aspect
is an amplification of the Yong aspect
that's always there it's always there so
the PO the Poetics is Heaven's always
pressing down on you God's always
pressing down on you okay but I'm going
to use my
materiality in conjunction with that cuz
I can't feel that I can't feel that yet
but I can feel my my own mouth first
okay and that's what I feel first well
maybe I can't feel that so I'm going to
add to it I'm going to add his MK to it
do you see I'm trying to make what is
extremely subtle to the mind the
untrained mind more gross so I can start
to sense it and then I started rotating
it you see I started rotating it in Tino
handles
you I want to get I now want to get it
down I want to get it down I want to
take it from top and I want to get it
down down up down take it I'm trying to
amplify that so I can feel it and that
showman the booty so already in your
stance your own Mass you should already
be able to do it just
like when we do our standing meditation
I don't even need to lower my Center
gravity okay the chi drops it'll drop
every time on me my lower spine just
goes okay but clearly I I'm not moving
it's inside I can't feel that or let's
lower your Center gravity a little bit
more and let's get your legs out of the
way that's that's what you're doing well
let's add some weight to
it see and I'm going to physically make
the physical center of gravity go up and
down in my body because it will affect
those Yin Andy aspects oh as I'm coming
up down and so as I'm doing this though
in the same way that I
release and stack my own Mass on the
ground
Vector everything all these Amplified
forces I do here as
well I don't want to sit here
this is not I what the is that
okay did the same way that my spine
cracked and pulled on itself without
me doing anything overtly physical
something happened
inside the more gross I
get I need some grossness to help me but
if I just stick on that I'm not going to
get there so as you're doing this feel
this feel this feel that tip heavy put
the tip on your midfoot
vector and as it goes
up slightly come up that's enough the
center gravity is going up with my hands
going up with the tip going
up but bring it up a little with your
body that's enough
inhale then let it
drop don't don't I'm not breathing to
make
it some
weird Tibetan Buddhist exercise on
not my lungs open as my armpits open I'm
released the air comes
in my lungs get pressed upon as my
armpits close I release the air comes
out
go at your
rate feel the center of gravity go
up feel it go
down okay so now we're trying to get
whatever you got with Yin and yangong
we're going to try to lower it now we're
trying to get it down okay
try okay so in that so far if you pay
attention uh on the tyo Hano drill where
I'm going to use some cental
energies to bring some grossness to this
what is not mechanically subtle or thin
but
mine hard to sense
mind hyphen hard hyphen to hyphen sense
okay
um in that one though I said you're
taking your own mass and stacking it so
you're already amplifying what I said is
always already
happening and then in the shman sabui
drill the same thing I said you're
stacking
yourself and then you're amplifying it
so you have your shoulder weight your
elbow weight your hand weight but also
the tip of the sword is
all being used to magnify amplify make
more sensibility to this to these forces
okay so we're going to do it here as
he's
sitting he's going to use his own
physicality he's going to let
his
head his
spine sink
drop because we want the chi not blocked
we want the chi
down why do we want the chi down the chi
has to go down so that it gets
alchemically treated when it gets
alchemically
treated your ego tripartite mind just
takes a back seat seat stops driving the
bus
deconstructs however you
want we want
that to this he can add his
shoulders as a as a upic pointer you
should feel your shoulders where you
feel your ground Vector right
now you should feel your elbows same
thing they hit that ground vector
same thing with his eyes he's not
seeing he's in the this blankness of his
gaze he can use his
hands if he feels like oh that's making
me lift my elbows okay he can come down
here but he puts his hand weight on that
same
thing he put puts his face skin on that
same thing everything's
dropping scan for
tension two key
areas this throat area
behind I'm touching the surface but it's
inside got it CH
okay and back
here again I'm touching the surfaces
inside more those you want to drop to
release to take away all tension to
forfeit all control of them to let them
do what they're going to do on their own
as you're doing everything
else you start from
there now we'll add the gross movements
but this year have to start from
okay so the one we're going to do
now we'll use two hands for symmetry
here just wait I haven't told you what
we're going to do I'm going to push down
on it okay and you're going to use your
physical posture to keep your hands to
support my weight got it okay so you
feel that so don't let your hands go
down there you go okay
now to keep this don't let your hands go
down pay attention to your ground Vector
point do you feel the weight is on there
you're using it do you get it okay go
back to just your weight and put it on
that ground Vector spot up again and let
it all drop
pay attention to those two spots forfeit
them very much like UK forfeits their
physical wellness you forfeit control of
these
spots and then we do it again hands come
up feel your ground first don't don't
Breet yet just bring your hands up
to
here now feel this weight of your
lifting your hands the weight of your
own hands put it on that ground Vector
too leave your hands
here then I'm going to
add don't lean back this
time but as if you were about to do you
understand put that in your hands
now I do want you to lean back like
mechanically there you go well you don't
have to come so awake in your in your
Consciousness good and then come
back and feel it before you lift it but
it's there ready to be lifted right
ready to be lifted ready to be
lifted Put Your Shoulder weight on that
same place that you're putting my finger
weight or elbow weight on that same
place and without lifting it I want you
to think that you're going to lift it
externally
there you
go
okay did you notice when you when you
came back and you went physical that you
like almost woke back up did you were
you guys able to see
that because that
external activates that ego tripartite
mind you come out of BL I don't want to
call it a Trans State
but you're out you're not in that ego
tripartite mind State okay and you can
see how it was like someone threw cold
water on him kind of came out of it
right away okay so when you when you do
that first one see if you have to do
that or not you don't have to do it so
much okay really key is this
person and then he's we're we're taking
advantage of his imagination because we
don't have the skills yet we're going to
use it okay the first one I'll just
repeat now what I'm doing he's going to
stack his own weight on
there the next one I'm giving him weight
and he's going to use his
external fuling to go down to to lift
his keep his hands up do you get it but
I draw his mind to the ground
Vector then I let him go
back set it up again
then we come up again we're going a
little fast for him but
okay and then I
touch and he is like he's going to fulum
but doesn't it's prelift this is your
pre push do you get it I was telling you
the other day what the pushable is what
you want not the push it's liftable now
do you see and then I let him go ahead
and do it externally he lifts it up
bringing back feels his ground pop cool
and now I'm going to have him come
back line everything back
up and go back to the
prelift there you
go and my weight with your shoulder
weight with your elbow weight your hand
weight is already just dropping down
straight
free your
throat free that back
spot and
rest good now don't stay
there and see how your skin is
stretching you see that see there's that
adhesion that keep that adion
feeling and you can actually move me now
okay slowly move my fingertips to still
pull me back with your hands yes see you
see there it is right
there
okay don't don't have to do the last one
okay all right here we
go okay so again we're using
external forces to create some
more sensibility to what we're trying to
sense
okay um his hands are back out let's see
how fast you can do
it it should it should feel like um or
can feel
like like
uh oil
like I take a cup of oil and I spill it
and it it's it starts to puddle spread
it should feel like that okay you'll
just feel it
go okay your hands are up feel that in
your the same mechanics bring your hands
up bring them in a little bit more and
then your weight weight of your hands is
doing the same thing don't forget those
two
spots now I'm going to come
underneath and I'm going to
lift but you're going to take that all
your mass right now keep your hands
heavy take my lifting on to you're going
to feel the
skin you see right
there so here don't change anything okay
here's what I what I mean by I say right
there the adhesion is right there you
can put your fingers straight if you
want and then I I can feel it you feel
it you see very you good so that's what
you're trying to
feel that's his coing
okay go back to it let let the oil spill
and spread downward through your
body your hand
weight is down and not letting me lift
you there you
go and there there it is right there
feel it and you if you pull your hands
back you'll pull me towards you yes yeah
there you go see good okay don't know
you took it off leave it on okay and now
leave it there and I want you to push me
back slowly push me back to where I was
up yep there it is up it goes keep going
till I'm
up there you
go and then I want you to take me
forward keep
it
fine the oil spill
down
ready take away the hooks it's all my
fingertips very
even good and push me there slowly
careful when you change directions don't
shut it off when you change
directions you're going to go back now
without shutting it off when you change
directions yeah there you
go and back forward without Shing it off
come back
forward that's
it and now we'll just hang here and keep
the same
feeling don't don't go into sleepy it's
not sleepy
so you can see that I can do the
same
okay um as you guys are doing
this who I'm having him do it but
obviously it's happening to me as zuk
too okay and so as
his ego triarte mind drops as Nas get
ego triarte mind drops yours will
draw you stay in that
same alchemical
organization and there is as much as
he again stays in that trance you'll
feel that come on to you that's what you
felt last time Margaret okay so when I
was leaving you for long periods of that
game neither push nor pull that had your
ego tripartite mind dropped and you felt
the the Ecstasy of the of that process
okay okay so again
what he and I not so much cuz he's
getting
it but what we're doing in these drills
and it's fine that you guys are is I'm
I'm using external forces to get you in
the
ballpark
okay um such that on this last drill I'm
I'm lifting you see and if he as long as
he keeps his hands down it generates a
friction there do you get it but at the
end there I'm barely touching him like
now I'm not lifting at all and you could
feel the same stick is
there you see which is you you can see
how relaxed we are but you can see that
you still have
it and that's what you want to get to
okay so if you're like I still feel
slippery right still feel then just tell
them to push more to generate more of
that the physical adhesion that comes
from two two contrary forces pushing on
each other but obviously that's not what
we're after
okay but there's some things
here
um to pay attention to okay so you'll be
the N okay and uh I'm going to let him
do it at whatever level he wants so I'm
not lifting on him at all he's just
resting on me okay um if I if you stays
there and I try to pull my hands back
what do you feel the force increase do
you see that and I because of how I'm
trained to pull my hands back it's going
into my center and you should feel your
Center going too you do feel the
pressure increase at the contact point
at the hands but you should feel your
ground Vector get heavier you see that
you feel that okay so I watch I'm going
to increase it if you couldn't feel it
and you'll feel the ground Vector get
heavier on your body as it starts to
pull on your Center you see that I'm
pulling him now okay so now I'm going to
go
back give you back
control take it back okay
more hands down weight of the hand down
M lifting pressure down
there it is okay so now go back to what
I want to say as I try to pull my hand
back it just moves me it's pulling on my
Center making me go forward as long as
he holds that there he holds the
relationship does not freak out on my
pull it starts to move me forward you
pay attention I'm moving more forward
don't let your hands move keep your
hands still keep your hands still in
space as if I'm pulling my there it is
and you see as I pull my hands pressure
is increasing it's just making me move
forward okay I'm going to let you
experience it
okay so there's the you feel the skin
okay and you're going to move you're
going to try to move your hands back and
I just keep you're going to try to make
your hands go that way okay and you're
going to feel there's the increase in
the hand contact pressure see and you
can see that he's moving forward he
starts to move forward okay and that's
stuff that you could exaggerate
as you do like the CQ game okay and uh
that doesn't
happen if he just grabs my
arm do you see he just grabs my arm
because I can pull that it doesn't make
me pull forward do you get it let's say
he holds it really really strongly
really
strongly uh right and you're like well
that would yeah but it takes more
strength on him to do that right the
other one didn't take any strength it
just happens and as he increases his
strength with his pool because he
doesn't have my my Center then I can
change my leverage do you see and then
externally and that's what all Grapplers
do okay he would be looking for
mechanical advantage and I would look
for a mechanical advantage and what the
energetic does it goes wherever you're
looking for your mechanical advantage by
repositioning your
Center it actually gets moved by me as
you reposition your Center okay that's
what happens that was the point I was
telling you at the end Virginia like you
moved into the projection Point not not
me bringing you in
right all right um same
thing if uh I'm
here get it again put your weight put
everything put my lifting on your mid
Vector spill the oil down your body come
on more pressure on your hands down
press down press down on your hands
there
okay get the stick and now hold it still
in space so I can't pull it and I can't
push
it think gu I think I'm going to push
you there it
is okay so the same thing as I go to
push you see what's happening I feel it
in my feet I feel it in my
center and I'm just pushing myself away
is what's
happening there it
is whereas if we're here and he's just
holding me like he's blocking me then I
can just
push doesn't affect my Center maybe it
turns me doesn't affect my Cent okay so
you feel it
okay you try and
push push harder and look at his
knees okay that and that's why if you
pay attention in the co cuc cane he will
not push on me okay cuz he knows that
that's I push on him I just going to get
projected out correct you bastard
okay but it's making me better at the
adhesion part the pulling energy the
controlling energy okay that's why he he
like don't push don't push okay all
right let's go to another
one make it even more grosser cuz we're
going to ask more of it and this is the
first the the the second iy drill
okay so um he's going to lift up so
there's more mass there do you see and
he's going to lift up on his arms and so
as he's
lifting you hold just like you were here
and I was lifting and he put that
organization in
place he's
lifting you're nog at me you're going to
feel the same you do the same organ
iation okay and you make him lift keep
lifting and then you just move the keep
you don't you keep lifting no matter
what and you move that
forward okay at this time we're going to
move our
body start in front you can start lower
if you want he
lifts I don't want you hooking here pull
it you can't have one rate okay it's a
feeling so here I can have one rate but
as it as his radius changes on his
shoulders you have to change that to
keep it to where the friction works for
you I'm slipping
[Music]
keep the
feeling okay try
no all right so as you come around there
it is right
there that same the same energy put your
arms together he's lifting up and I
generate that same
friction the
adhesion by the same
organization I am going to
do here stay there come to the other
side
maret is right here so my
M down down his
Mass down on my ground
Vector the centrifugal
energy down okay and that don't
grab that's what you
use and it's going to change as you cut
the angle and as he's falling okay it
changes so the
feeling is what you
want the feeling
you feel it on your
face so you have to move to
keep the
feeling you have to lower to keep the
feeling you have to rotate to keep the
feeling you going to be in the right
place to keep the feeling at the right
time to keep the feeling
okay this
way okay I only wanted to actually
concentrate on the adhesion part okay
but this has a spiral the
spiral don't don't grab him don't cut
down he goes
around okay and after it goes around it
comes
back this
way okay it's going to come back this
way it'll never get there but that's
what it's
doing guys
over here you're here like this okay
this is that same adhesion don't
chase the
mechanical release your hand your hand
and do
this you have the same adhesion this do
it together the two forces are doing
it so I show you what I mean by that
home this horse is doing it right there
you see it's taking them that way it's
not taking them this
way contact
[Music]
Point okay on the
adhesion you can do this where you make
a big
one cuz you kept the same
radius but that's not what I'm
doing you see
that this radius gets
smaller so it starts big but then
instead of going this
way it's
going this way
that's what takes his
balance you feel
that it gets smaller
[Music]
okay TR on one rep he let go but that it
demonstrates a point so we're going to
tell him to let go so we're here he's
going to let
go you're going to be able to do it with
the slightest angle he lets go it
doesn't
matter get the adhesion so
it's there cuz you have the adhesion
okay going keep the same technique let's
go still let's
[Music]
go still okay try
is
[Music]